secretary-general thank you for talking
to our new program sit on it
SOS may I start with looking at the safe
of the world the war in Syria now in its
ninth year well over half a million
people dead the situation in Yemen also
very very bad the worst humanitarian
crisis on earth the war in Libya
reignited in recent months and we've got
unresolved conflicts all around the
world Somalia Afghanistan Central
African Republic when you look at that
picture
why are you concentrating so much on
climate that some might say is not such
an immediate problem well first of all
let me congratulate aljazeera to launch
a climate show regularly I think it's a
very good contribution to help people
around the world know about the
challenges of climate change
now we don't neglect all these conflicts
on the contrary I mean they occupy
probably the overwhelming majority of
our time and of our initiatives there is
a constant diplomacy if a peace even if
the circumstances as you know are not
easy and we face many obstacles to make
sure that we are able to prevent
conflicts and to timely solve the
conflicts we still have but we need to
recognize that the threat of each of
these conflicts is to a certain extent
localized and climate change became a
global threat for humankind and the
global threat for the planet and things
are evolving in such a way that climate
change became an accelerator of conflict
if you look at the silo the CEO is
probably today the most complex
environment interaction to conflict and
terrorism you know in an area that is
expanding it started with Mali now it
impacts Burkina Faso and nisha and it's
threatens to come to the car to the
countries of the coast that recently
echo has met as you know and decided to
create to put their standby force also
in support of the operations against
terrorism in the area it is clear that
climate change making the certification
progress making others more and more in
difficult and moving south to
communities where farmers are creating
more conflicts climate change is
becoming a
accelerating factor of many of the
conflicts in the world some people even
say for instance that one of the factors
that contributed to the Arab Spring was
the level of drought in some of those
countries now I I'm not necessarily
saying that is climate change that is
causing all the conflicts around the
world but it is clear that climate
change is in itself a threat to us all
and at the same time is one of the
accelerating factors of conflict when
world leaders gather here in New York
you have convened a climate summit you
said to those world leaders don't come
with a speech come with a plan what do
you want to hear now it's very simple we
are losing the race climate change is
running faster than what we are things
are getting worse by the day we see
that's all these Astor's becoming more
and more intense more frequent with more
devastating consequence I just came from
the Bahamas where I could witness the
dramatic devastation of Hurricane Dorian
on the other hand you look at the last
months of July it was the hottest month
on record we will have from 2015 to 2019
the five hottest years on record and at
the same time we see glaciers melting we
see for instance the ice cap of
Greenland as lost in July two hundred
and ninety seven billion tons of ice so
melting into the ocean so you see that
the rising waters in the oceans the
increase of temperatures the
multiplication of natural disasters the
dramatic impacts of drought in different
parts of the world all these is creating
a situation that is a real threat to
humankind and we are not doing enough
what was decided in Paris was very
important the Paris agreement is a
fundamental pillar to defeat climate
change but the targets that were fixed
and that later the scientific community
through the Intergovernmental Panel on
Climate Change is clarified that we need
to maintain the growth of them
below the level of 1.5 degrees at the
end of the century and for that we need
to be carbon neutral in 2050 and we need
to have a very meaningful reduction of
about 45% of emissions in 2030 and for
that what was promised in Paris is not
enough and as it what was wrong as what
was promised in Paris is not enough and
countries are supposed in 2020 to renew
their engagements the so-called national
determined contributions this summit is
exactly to ask countries to make sure
that they renew their engagements
increasing ambition which means tough
decisions that need to be taken in
relation to fossil fuels tough decisions
that need to be taken in relation to the
transformation of the way we produce
food we power our economies we generate
energy
we support mobility so all these
requires a very strong political will in
order to be able to stop this dramatic
race in which climate change is winning
what do you do them about those
countries I'll call them the difficult
customers countries like Australia like
Brazil like the u.s. that pulled out of
the Paris climate deal how do you
persuade them well we are doing our best
to persuade countries but especially
this is also a summit to address the
public opinions in general governments
will do largely in the end what public
opinions tell them to do on the even in
countries where governments are
reluctant to act in relation to climate
change we see fantastic movements in the
civil society in the business community
in cities in regions and this summit is
also an opportunity for those entities
to come to present their plans and to
tell governments that they also need to
act because as I said this is now a
global threat that is a threat to the
planet but it's a threat for all of us
but among the public opinion there are
the deniers there are those that say the
science isn't settled that scientists
disagree there are those that say in
history the temperature has gone up in
the past and it's come back down what do
you say to people that
always denials in relation to every
truce that exists in the world but what
we see and if we follow Paul's around
the world you'll see that the number of
people denying it is diminishing very
quickly and the number of people
considering that climate change is the
defining issue of our time is the
biggest threat that we face is
increasing very rapidly and more and
more public opinions and even
electorates are giving a very strong
signal to governments that they need to
consider proper climate change a real
priority but it's some of the people who
deny this let me read you a quote I'm
not denying climate change but it could
well go back that quote was from the end
of last year it was said by President
Donald Trump what do you say to him I'm
saying that science is now clear and the
best available science that we have in
the world is telling us without any
doubt that climate change is the biggest
threat that our communities face in the
United States and around the world
you seem very keen not to directly
criticize he's wrong on this isn't he
and he's the most powerful man on the on
earth you were at the g7 summit he
skipped the session of climate and
afterwards let me just tell you what he
said to the reporters who were there we
are the number one energy producer in
the world and I'm not going to lose that
wealth I'm not going to lose it on
dreams on windmills which frankly aren't
working too well dreams and windmills
you need to confront that day the truth
is and it's very simple
today renewable energy is the cheapest
form of energy and even in the United
States renewable energy is creating mad
mad jobs then the production of energy
by coal or oil and so it is clear that
the windmills of different sorts solar
wind other forms of renewable the future
and I'm absolutely sure that these will
be recognized fully by the American
society moving from the u.s. to China
the other big emitter they are involved
in this massive belton road
infrastructure
project the biggest project of its type
on earth are you worried that that's not
going to be environmentally friendly now
I was in Beijing recently and I was
asked to speak about the need to green
the belt and roads we are concerned with
the fact that coal namely in Asia is
still a very important component in
relation to the production of energy and
more than that that there are a number
of coal power plants in preparation for
the future and they have been supported
in different Asian countries and namely
supported by countries like China Japan
or Korea and our pressure I was in Tokyo
been in Beijing has been very clearly to
say that it's time to consider that new
coal power plants should not be built
and progressively in the future we
should be phasing out coal if I may
there is a criticism of you and it was
made of your predecessor as well which
is that you are not prepared to stand up
to the five permanent members of the
Security Council on this issue which you
say is so crucial are you prepared to
confront them even if it costs you a
second term as Secretary Jay I don't
care about a second term I care about
doing the right thing if there is
someone that has been very clear in
relation to climate change if there is
someone that has been telling everybody
that this is the fundamental battle of
our time
and that we really need to change course
I think I'm at ease in this regard
and so with or with the United States or
China with Russia or whether I've been
telling all of them that they need to do
everything in order to make sure that we
reach carbon neutrality in 2050 and that
temperatures will not grow above 1.5
degrees at the end of the century and
that means dramatic choices inversion to
energy coke for instance and aversion to
all other aspects before you were an
international diplomat and now the top
international diplomat you were a
politician a socialist politician can I
ask you where you think the root of the
problem with climate change comes from
and is part of it the focus on the
markets and unbridled capitalist you
know I'm very proud of what I did in
Portugal as Prime Minister
you probably see if we look at
statistics today that portrays a high
percentage of energy produced by
renewables and this was done through
legislation that we introduced 20 years
ago in which the grid was forced to buy
at the time with a subsidized price
today it's no longer necessary because
the renewable energy is cheaper but at
the time the grid was forced to buy any
production of renewable energy and this
has boosted enormously the investment in
renewables in Portugal so what I did as
Prime Minister is what I'm asking all
governments in the world to do is to do
to take the adequate measures in
regulations in support without needing
any more to do subsidies to renewables
what they need is to cut the subsidies
that go on being given to fossil fuels
there is it doesn't make any sense that
taxpayers money my money as a taxpayer
can go to boost hurricanes or to bleach
corals or to melt glaciers through this
subsidizing fossil fuels that today are
no longer able to compete with
renewables because renewables became the
cheapest way to produce electricity so
in some of those other countries unlike
Portugal was that too much of a focus on
the free market and capitalism without
thinking about the effects of the free
market and capitalism is a question of
wrong choices wrong choices made by the
government and wrong choices made by the
markets and what the markets are also
now showing is that indeed the future is
in renewables look at the number of
asset managers asset managers
representing 34 trillion dollars have
said to the leaders of g20
time to change course time to have
climate action as a priority you see for
instance even if the sovereign fund of
Norway is largely generated by the
production of oil in Norway you see that
the sovereign fund of Norway now the S
that is divesting from fossil fuels
based on the decision of the origin
Parliament and you see a coalitions of
banks coalition's of pension funds and
other entities that decided to have now
climate as a key
element in the way they do business and
you see central bank's drawing the
attention for the risks of climate when
they do economic calculations so even
markets are today recognizing that they
need to incorporate carbon as a cost
we've talked about countries and the
United Nations is an organization built
on countries member states but let's
talk about individuals what should they
be doing because the jargon is confusing
the sciences confusion fusing should
ordinary people be giving up beef should
they give up flying I mean I fly a lot
you fly a lot as befits the Secretary
General you fly first-class what should
ordinary individuals do I think we we
need also to look into our own footprint
and I believe there that we are having a
fantastic question from the youth the
use as yesterday had their own summit
here in the United Nations they had
their own March and the use is telling
their parents that we also need to
change many of the aspects of our daily
life I'll give you an example you have
here a glass of water
plastic single-use plastics have been
abolished in the UN headquarters and
they need to be abolished everywhere in
the world so we all need to change our
habits it's very practical to have a
small bottle of plastic for the water
but we need to abolish them because they
are undermining the health of our oceans
and the health of our people so again in
climate change as in pollution in all
aspects we also need to recognize our
contribution and we need to think
strongly about what we need to change in
our lives you've spoken about the youth
these protests we've seen Greta
Thornburg we've seen outside the United
Nations leading these school strikes do
you think it's time for you as
secretary-general to use this moment and
perhaps use social media to reach above
the Member States and communicate
directly with the people and I'm trying
to do it myself
and to be clear this summit was preceded
as you have seen by a youth summit
exactly because we believe that today
public opinions are more ready to accept
the need to change than politicians
themselves and that it is very
important that public opinions push
their governments push their political
systems to take the right decisions
let's take stock of exactly where we are
with the science I mean you're not a
scientist but in your job you're briefed
by the very best scientists in the world
even if we manage to turn things around
what damage has already been done to the
earth in terms of lost species for
example now we see biodiversity is one
of the most dramatic aspects of today's
world we are losing species at a
dramatic speed and this is only this is
not only linked to climate change it's
also linked to destruction of habitats
in many parts of the world to the way we
have neglected nature in many other
aspects but what is clear for me is that
we absolutely need to reconcile
humankind with nature if you look at
history history is full of examples of
people fighting each other I think for
the first time people are fighting the
creation people are fighting mother
nature so we need to recognize this and
we need to change course obviously there
are scientists with different views on
this but from what you're being told how
might have different views but nature is
angry and I've seen it in the Bahamas
but when you have 200 more than 200
miles-per-hour winds that stay in an
island for two days destroying
everything
mother nature is angry whatever they
want but the majority overwhelming
majority of scientists recognize why
mother nature is angry and mother nature
is angry because we are making it angry
with what we are doing pushing for
climate change and the Bahamas
definitely climate change in your fear I
mean there always we always every case
but now the Erika is more intense more
frequent and with more devastating
consequences and there is only simple as
the temperature of the water increases
there is more evaporation as there is
more evaporation there is more mass of
water in the air storms become of course
much more intense than they were in the
past in terms of this becoming
irreversible what are you being told by
the scientists how long do we have to we
don't have much time
we have probably 12 years 11 12 years to
change course if not it will be
irreversible that we will not be able to
contain the increase of temperatures at
1.5 degrees at the end of the century
which means that we will have inevitably
much more catastrophic impacts of
climate change than the ones that we are
now seeing in today's world your family
man secretary general when you think of
your children your grandchildren and
their future does this issue the climate
crisis does it keep it up keep you up at
night it's central in my life I have
three granddaughters I have no idea of
the world will be when they have they
will have my age they are between five
and ten years old so when they will be
70 the world will be completely
different but one thing is clear my
generation has the obligation to allow
them to live in a healthy planet and we
are not fulfilling that obligation we
are destroying the planet in which they
will have to live